so Donald Trump's personal attorney rudy
guiliani who you might remember was
completely pulled off of TV after one
disastrous appearance after another
before the molar report and bar letter
came out he's been allowed back on TV
and he has had some very strange
appearances in the last week with CNN's
Chris Cuomo which maybe we'll get to
later in the week but he had an
absolutely off-the-rails breakdown
during an interview with Chris Wallace
on Fox News Chris Wallace one of the
occasional voices of not even reason but
just some moderate level of sanity on
Fox News and Rudy Giuliani kept trying
to go back to talk about Hillary Clinton
and her emails during this interview and
Chris Wallace did the right thing in the
context he pushed back and at one point
Giuliani loses his temper and he says
well who made Robert Muller God and of
course the key point here is that the
Muller report says there's substantial
evidence of obstruction but as part of
this fantasy world that Trump and his
people continue to craft they keep
insisting it's crazy to be talking about
obstruction take a look
mother says the injury to the justice
system is just as great it doesn't
matter whether there was an underlying
crime it's still obstruction when did
mullet become God MOA says the injury to
the justice system is still is great
there was no injury by the way we're
talking about an inchoate crime we're
talking about something that didn't
happen
there was no obstruction nothing was
denied him nobody crushed cellphones
like Hillary did nobody a deleted 33,000
emails like Hillary's people did and
nobody bleached a server like Hillary
did just keeps going back time and time
again to Hillary's emails and bleaching
and I watched the entire interview and
there must have been a dozen mentions of
Hillary Clinton by Rudy Giuliani if the
report actually exonerates your client
why do you keep talking about Hillary
because the report doesn't exonerate his
client and later Chris Wallace turns it
around on Rudy and actually says who
made you God and then there's this
amazing moment where with only 16
seconds of space between
statements Rudy says Hilary committed a
crime and then immediately says I'm not
saying she committed a crime you got 30
seconds why is that a problem for
Hillary Clinton but it isn't Clinton was
guilty of the underlying crime she did
crush she did crush the cell phone she
did who made you God as you said about
Muller
I'm not thought about more I'm just yeah
doesn't know we're saying that who made
dogs and I don't make mother Gotham
you're favoring whether she was guilty
or not saying there's a difference
between the time the same she's guilty
and I'm the difference well you actually
did just say she's guilty and now you're
saying you didn't say that she's guilty
I mean this stuff is on video it's on
video not even on different days not
even in different hours it's 16 seconds
that went by and they're gonna have to
pull the guy off TV again III don't
understand how this helps Trump in any
way I know earlier sowing confusion may
have been a strategy to just make it
unclear what's going on and who believes
what I don't know how this helps Trump
and there's another question on the
Giuliani stuff which is is there a
problem that media outlets keep
interviewing him what I mean is
Trump quoted Rudy Giuliani quoted Trump
one day a few months ago and the next
day when he was asked to defend that
quote said oh no that wasn't an actual
quote of Trump that was a hypothetical
quote of Trump should corporate media
simply have said no more Rudy Giuliani
because this is not providing anything
of value to anybody if he quotes someone
and then the next day says it wasn't
really a quote it was a hypothetical
quote of what Trump could have or would
have told me Chris Wallace sort of doing
what he should here although again
existing as a voice of sometimes dissent
within a very narrow parameter on fox
news but big picture there's a question
of whether Rudy Giuliani should even be
interviewed on corporate media period
let me know what you think